Còn chỉ là ph đường xử ớ, đó là cả một thành chình mẹ đồng thành cùng con quanh qua thiếu hụt mĩnh sịch.
Giọ này, lứa ph ph thái tốt mà không thấy bức tường xử của các mẹ đình thị đúng là các món vỏ lưới một trẻ nghiệp vô cùng tủ vị.
Từ quay phải lox sử xin sinh đến cả ra tại sếp cao trạm đó,
trên phước sử xử dạc hình xử với báo khi các mẹ cung nhau xử xẻ hình chình với con mạng tất cả tiền yêu thường.
Nhưng đằng sau những bức tường xử nguyên thiếu vui vui vui ấy, là cả một câu chuyện rất thật.
Đó là những ngày con bước vào giải đảng thiếu hụt mĩnh sịch,
thưa điểm hệ mĩnh sịch của con con nó nốt, chỉ cần đủ xóa hai trời trời là xúc xin hai.
Còn như đêm con họ, mẹ thông thức tường xam,
con những mức mẹ đồng nhất vẫn là con họ,
trọc sữa nào đi vừa vừa vừa đi khám,
tăng ký vừa dú còn tục.